Водень. "Енергоносій майбутнього". Колись він має стати рушійним елементом нової енергетичної політики Європи.
Так вважають і в цьому порту Роттердама. Фірма-оператор планує перевести цілий порт на водневу енергомережу.
І перетворити таким чином порт Роттердама на міжнародну водневу розв'язку: для виробництва, імпорту і транспорту водню в інші європейські країни.
Але чи справді водень як енергоносій - зелений?
Власне, водень сам по собі безбарвний.
Але щоб краще розрізняти, залежно від процесу його виробництва, водню присвоюють різні фарби: сірий, блакитний або зелений.
Нині переважна більшість водню у світі - із сірої категорії. Його видобувають з викопного пального на кшталт природного газу чи вугілля.
І такий водень - шкідливий для довкілля. Оскільки процес його виробництва спричиняє велетенські викиди СО2.
Блакитний водень, по суті, теж сірий. Його теж видобувають з викопної сировини.
Однак в процесі його видобутку шкідливий вуглець "відловлюють" і зберігають у газових сховищах. Тож викиди СО2 при цьому значно менші.
Зелений водень - це той, який видобувають з води. Лише цей вид може вважатися сприятливим для довкілля.
Усі різновиди - це один і той же водень, адже формула його молекули - Н2.
Але різні процеси видобутку є вирішальними щодо того, наскільки високими є парникові викиди і наскільки чистий цей водень.
Процес електролізу виглядає наступним чином: воду розщеплюють на кисень і водень. А саме - за допомогою струму.
Цей струм, щоправда, так само не завжди отриманий "зеленим" шляхом.
Чистим водень є лише тоді, коли струм походить з відновлювальних джерел енергії - вітру або сонця - тобто цілковито без викидів СО2.
Зелений, дружній до довкілля і екологічний означає, що водень видобутий за допомогою відновлювальних джерел енергії.
Але що, коли країна не може покрити всю потребу лише зеленим воднем?
У Німеччині, приміром, вітер і сонце не дають достатньо енергії.
За оцінками, до 2050 року ФРН потрібно буде імпортувати 45 мільйонів тонн водню.
Важливо, щоб транспортування на далеку відстань - танкерами або трубопроводами - також не завдало додаткової шкоди довкіллю.
Нам потрібна глобальна система сертифікації, аби можна було довести, що цей водень справді видобуто за допомогою зеленого струму.
Такої системи сертифікації наразі не існує. Домовитися щодо неї поки не змогли.
Однією з перешкод на шляху переходу на зелений водень є його ціна.
Якщо нині за існуючих регуляторних приписів видобутий з відновлювальних джерел енергії зелений або блакитний водень
порівняти з існуючими традиційними видами енергії, то це - доволі таки дорогий варіант.
Разом з тим, чим більше вироблятиметься зеленої енергії, тим дешевшим ставатиме й зелений водень.
Згідно з прогнозами, його ціна до 2030 року зменшиться вдвічі.
Однак поки що зелений водень у ЄС не дуже поширений.
За оцінками експертів, блакитний водень - тобто зі збереженням СО2 у сховищах - ще роками відіграватиме вирішальну роль.